und dann kneten und dann
Hauptsache voll gelandet
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
ich hatte eine Vision von einer Schnecke
einer Zuckerschnecke und zwar liebe ich
ja Zimtschnecken nussschnecken alle
möglichen Arten von Schnecken außer
Weinbergschnecken das mag ich nicht das
will ich auch nicht probieren aber süße
Schnecken mag ich und ich hatte eine
Vision vielleicht kennt ihr das dass ihr
auch Berliner oder Krapfen wie es halt
in vielen anderen Regionen heißt die gab
es früher auch oft mit so Zucker drauf
nicht mit Puderzucker sondern mit Zucker
so kristallzucken wenn man so rein weißt
dann knirscht das so in den Zähnen und
ich möchte heute
Zuckerschnecken machen das heißt ich
mache einen Hefeteig damit es gerollt
damit der Zuckerschnecke gebacken dann
habe ich mir gedacht nach dem Backen
bestreiche ich sie so flüssig mit Mutter
und dann trinke ich sie in Zucker
Zuckerschnecke kann man das machen
klingt doch voll gut oder vielleicht
mache ich in Erfüllung noch was
schokoladiges oh mein Gott ich freue
mich so sehr auf dieses Rezept deswegen
zeige ich euch hier mal den Hefeteig ich
habe hier Zucker und Butter reduziert
weil er später Zucker noch mal drauf
kommt damit nicht so süß wird am Ende
dafür verwendet ihr einen Würfel Hefe 30
g Wasser 60 g Zucker 500 g Mehl dann
nehmt ihr Weizen oder Dinkelmehl 250 g
Milch jeweils einen Teelöffel Salz und
Kardamom das ist gemahlener Kardamom
eine Teelöffel Vanilleextrakt ein Ei und
60 g weiche Butter
ich freue mich denn ich hatte viel zu
lange keine Zuckerschnecken mehr keine
süßen Hefeschnecken also ihr gebt jetzt
die Hefe hier rein falls ihr keine
frische Hefe da habt gehen auch zwei
Tütchen Trockenhefe
Wasser und Zucker dazu
dann kurz verrühren
jetzt gebe ich alle anderen Zutaten dazu
ich gebe immer erstmal Mehl drauf auf
die Hefe damit Salz und Butter erst zum
Schluss mit der Hefe in Verbindung
kommen und dann knetet ihr den Teig etwa
10 Minuten lang schön geschmeidig
und Kardamom ist hier richtig gut denn
Kardamom gibt einfach so einen tollen
Geschmack und ich glaube das passt
später alles perfekt zueinander
[Musik]
ich brauche eine Unterstützung
reicht für heute weiter geht's mit
backen
so ist der Teig perfekt wenn er nicht
mehr klebt und dann nehmt ihr ihn kurz
aus der Schüssel raus knetet eine Kugel
daraus und die lasst ihr dann etwa eine
Stunde aufgehen bis sie sich verdoppelt
hat oder ihr könnt sie auch mit
hitzefunktion und erkennen wo drauf
gehen lassen für ungefähr eine
Dreiviertelstunde oder auch im Backofen
bei gerstufe falls ihr einen
Dampfbackofen habt dann dauert das ganze
nur 30 Minuten
so sieht mein Hefeteig jetzt aus
wunderschön ich liebe Hefeteig und hier
habe ich jetzt noch drei Zutaten nämlich
100 g Butter 40 g Kakao und 100 g Zucker
die brauche ich nämlich gleich zum
befüllen
einfach schön
und den Rolle ich jetzt zu einem großen
Rechteck aus mit etwas Mehl
[Musik]
so machen wir den 5 mm Ring mal weg denn
ich möchte 3 mm
[Musik]
so sieht's perfekt aus und bei Hefeteig
ist immer ganz gut wenn er mal nicht
ganz so rechteckig geworden ist zieht
ihr ihn und formt ihn einfach in die
richtige Richtung und dann passt es auch
schön nehme ich die weiche Butter und
streiche hier drauf
[Musik]
wenn ihr das dann habt
kommen der Zucker und der Kakao noch
drüber einfach schön verteilen und noch
mal mit der Palette verstreichen
[Musik]
schön sieht das aus
ich meine ihr könnt euch ja auch
einfacher machen und zum Beispiel dann
muss Nougat-Creme reinstreichen aber ich
will nicht dass es zu süß wird am Ende
deswegen lieber so vor allem habe ich so
einfach richtig schön so eine fette
Kakao Schicht
jetzt kann ich hier mit Hilfe der
Backmatte das zu einer Rolle aufräumen
[Musik]
dann nehme ich mir jetzt ein bisschen
Faden der muss gar nicht so lang sein
wenn ihr mal keinen Faden zu Hause habt
geht auch Zahnseide zum Beispiel und
jetzt werden die Schnecken geschnitten
und weil ich sie mit dem Messer
zerdrücken würde nehmt ihr den Faden
weil dann kann man schön in Knoten
machen von außen nach innen jetzt
entscheidet ihr selbst wie groß die
Schnecken werden sollen wie dick sie
sein sollen ich habe jetzt einfach mal
die Rolle und ich denke ich mache mal so
16 Stück da raus ja also hier einfach
drum legen und
zack
wegschneiden
doch weniger damit ich größer
[Musik]
so sind sie jetzt schon wunderschön und
die kommen jetzt gleichzeitig in den
Ofen einfach auf eben eins und Ebene 3
der Ofen ist jetzt noch kalt dann
schalte ich ihn an und während der Ofen
vorheizt haben die Schnecken noch mal
die Gelegenheit etwas aufzugeben was ich
nach dem Backen dann machen werde ist
folgendes sobald sie aus dem Ofen raus
sind werde ich sie mit flüssiger Butter
bestreichen und dann in Zucker tauchen
so habe ich mir vorgestellt
[Musik]
das ist so schön wenn Träume wahr werden
und wenn Visionen zur gebackenem werden
genauso habe ich mir euch vorgestellt
ich musste selber bestaunen
du bist der schneckenexperte der
hefeschneckenexperte hier
[Musik]
Schnecken du bist der der immer am
besten
verkostetig aussehen
Perfektion einfach
oh mein Gott wie es mir vorgestellt habe
dass man so runter
mein Gott
wo sind die lecker
die sind der Hammer das will ich da noch
sagen guckt euch das mal an
die riechen so gut oh mein Gott
die besten Hefeschnecken die ich hier
gemacht habe
ich habe jetzt das ganze Ding irgendwas
ich glaube ich muss das jetzt essen oder
ich glaube auch hoch hoppala
oh mein Gott
wirklich probiert das Rezept bitte aus
und bitte bitte nimmt Kardamom ihr
werdet es nicht bereuen am besten macht
ihr gleich die doppelte Menge denn sonst
werdet ihr es bereuen ja ich werde es
auf jeden Fall auch nochmal auf jeden
Fall also Unrecht was cool ist bei dir
ist ja auch cool wenn du z.B daheim bist
und du bist vielleicht alleine und dann
brauche ich jetzt nicht ein ganzes Blech
aber man kann ja diese Schnecke die man
gemacht hat und geschnitten hat die
können die auch einfrieren und dann habt
ihr immer so eine Schnecke die aufbacken
könnt dann kannst du super vorbereiten
das ist perfekt
haben wieso diese Ikea Schnecken die man
so kaufen kann und dann kannst Du eben
immer Backen voll gut also macht's gut
bis zum nächsten mal das Rezept findet
ihr meine App oder auch.de tschüss
[Musik]